and this one's the car we're so excited
about our new sponsor sakara it's the
ultimate hot girl food it's
nutritionally designed chef crafted
breakfast lunch and dinner and they're
made with powerful plant-rich
ingredients you can um sacara's offering
our listeners 20 off their first order
when they go to sakara.com
trash tuesday or answer the code trash
tuesday at checkout that's
s-a-k-a-r-a dot com slash trash tuesday
for 20 off your first order
truebill is a new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about
because companies make subscriptions so
hard to cancel true bill makes it
incredibly simple just link your
accounts and true bill will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap you
guys don't fall for subscription scams
start canceling today at truebill.com
trash tuesday go right now truebill.com
trash tuesday it could save you
thousands a year you guys nutriful is
vitamins for your hair simple as that it
supports healthy hair growth from within
by targeting five root causes of
thinning stress hormones environment
nutrition and metabolism imagine having
all of those problems right here
in your very fun job
we love neutrophil and you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to nutrafull.com
trash and save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to you
as customers for a limited time this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy life can be overwhelming
and many people are burned out without
even knowing it and symptoms can include
lack of motivation feeling helpless or
trapped attachment fatigue and more
so many things that we literally talk
about on this episode this podcast is
sponsored by better betterhelp and trash
tuesday listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash trash tuesday i am doing
up dates check them out astronics.com i
know i'm coming to austin in dc and i'm
adding more estronized.com for tickets
hey guys i'm so excited i'm going back
to flappers and burbank it's going to be
one show we're going to pack it out sell
it out i'm going to bring all of my
friends it's gonna be so absolutely
amazing and fun last time was incredible
i cannot freaking wait draw on your abs
get yourselves ready
come see me you never know what's gonna
happen things got crazy this last
weekend i've had so much fun i can't
wait to see more of you i'm also going
to be uh next weekend the following
weekend after this weekend the 24th
through the 25th i will be in west niacc
new york i cannot wait to go the flight
was so expensive please show up
i literally can't believe it it was
amazing uh and then i'm taking july off
but then you can see me
again in austin texas springfield
missouri homestead pa pittsburgh improv
tempe arizona calusa california casino
um
kansas city missouri there's a lot of
dates uh go to my website annie
letterman dot com shows there's many
more i can't wait to see you it's more
fun than i can even express to you
[Music]
esther you look like you um barred your
babysitter swimsuit to be here today
i was a guy
i just want to say that annie when the
moment you walked in today things
changed for me
well hold on
i
and kalyla
you will
you're you'll always be my number one
you'll always be my first oh thank you
but annie today
i'll be your last
we're gonna have sex i'm gonna choke you
too hard
you're not gonna make it
pamela
you're here i did can you see my
eyebrows on camera i tried to thin out
my eyebrows can you tell
uh yes
carlos let's see yours
yes oh wow has the best give us a run so
we can slow slow it down
just like run from here yeah like david
hasselhoff we'll slow it down
[Laughter]
that's our intro like carla it's so
weird that a guy has the body that i
want to have myself you're getting there
don't worry thank you
you guys welcome to the baywatch episode
is this what this is each pound you lose
in those tits you're getting closer to
carlos
esther was like a triple e before i have
to admit that i
have never seen baywatch
and it was your idea to do it yeah
because so esther that's so esther
but obviously we all know the iconic
looks
i'm just like hungry for you today i
wish that you saw baywatch because it
was epic did you used to watch it i yeah
i watched it that seems like one like
the only show that the philippines goes
well that and rescue 9-1-1 oh rescue
number you remember that and the glory
enactments right yeah and the gary
chandling show okay and wimbledon
wimbledon was a show no no no
yeah we got all the grand slams in the
philippines oh
um
[Laughter]
it's pride month it is oh yeah
congratulations
to you esther oh thank you carlos have
you been getting extra shout outs this
month
no not more than usual
people love you
there was a guy in the audience
i was in um
st louis i had so much fun there was a
guy in the audience who was with a girl
and he but he had a little bit of a
carlos vibe
so but i didn't want to say anything you
know and then eventually he was like i'm
gay girl and i was like oh my god i
didn't want to like
i saved that for carlos
and everyone erupted into laughter
i set out cards like i'm not gay
i'm never no i'm glad that it everybody
just want you know like the world's with
you thank you i i helped with a laugh
too and then i signed this girl has
didn't have knuckles she was born
without knuckles because i always ask
people if they have any deformities
they'd like me to sign yeah so she had
missing knuckles and i drew little
hearts and on one of them i wrote carlos
needs a haircut i saw that oh yeah i saw
that on there
on our instagram that is really bring me
your knobs okay so esther you never
watch baywatch no what do i need to know
there are a few characters that were
iconic which is obviously pammy yes yes
pamela whose name was uh i watched her
like later cj cj
cj then david hasselhoff david
hasselhoff's son
uh who is that guy jeremy jackson hobie
um then there was yasmine
bleath was on it um nicole edgar yeah
nicole egger who was famous did you
watch uh charles in charge she was the
hottie on charles in charge yeah i know
everyone was about cj but i really
thought um nicole eggert was it for me
oh she was my favorite 100
she was so hot and then i'm the
stephanie of the group yeah stephanie
we're actually technically stephanie's
but we've really squished it together
stephanie was just a random athletic
short-haired short hair they're waiting
for jason momoa on baby he was jason
malmo is on behalf of the last like not
in the early years right how many
seasons did it happen tonight
carmen elect later on as well
we i can't look at jesus
oh [ __ ] this is so cute this is crazy
wait i don't know if i've told you guys
this on the show before but so you know
how dave used to like work in late night
tv which is so i bought on the carson
daily show yes yeah so random did it
three times you'd never know
like a hundred times he told me that one
time he heard from one of the late night
producers like high up like letterman
all the like
just like knew about all the shows that
the only guests who ever moved the
needle ratings wise were two people pam
anderson and carmen electra of course
that makes sense so when those [ __ ]
were on they got more viewers and like
so that hot being hot is all that
matters
i mean really when you think about it
like jen mccarthy's crushing it still
and she's probably the one that's still
the hottest was she on baywatch she
wasn't but she was carmen electra was on
um singled out too so that's why i went
to
she was on singled out but she but they
were like
i love the jenny mccarthy show i guess
carmen electra actually came out with an
only fans recently carlos will you sign
up for it i i will it's fine will you
beard sign up for common lectures you
know who we had on our on tiger belly
was um um dave navarro oh yeah and they
used to be just they were remembering
yeah well they were married for a minute
and
bobby went to their like
co-bachelor
i think like back in the day when it was
still when it was a show on vh1 it was
on i think it was on and tv i watched it
me too they had a bachelor bachelorette
party i remember they like invented that
but bobby lee was there yeah he's well
he's friends with dave they've been
friends forever apparently
um and i was you know um in high school
just getting fisted by the wrong people
doctors brothers
[Laughter]
wow teachers
oh wait so many of these people ended up
getting so much attention that they
ended up becoming like drug addicts and
having to go to then they're probably on
celebrity rehab and stuff too so weird
to get this type of famous
like pamela anderson that thing coming
out must have been a [ __ ] nightmare
for her that what thing the pant the sex
tape
well obviously the sex tape but then
when they just redid it on fx i know it
was
neither pam or tommy wanted that it's so
crazy i know i i saw brittany being like
triggered online brittany ferland a
little bit but well who wouldn't you
know i know i really think about her
during that yeah i honestly like i feel
for her like everyone is just again
re-visiting people that didn't even know
what happened right
right
no one needs to go through that
emotional turmoil like yes for our
entertainment and if you're not making
money off of it that's way worse the
rule is post-mortem right like when
everyone has passed you can do that but
for for regular people to like interpret
your story and put a spin their spin on
it and then people consume it and say
hey this must have been the truth even
if you put a disclaimer like hey guys
this is you know not accurate people are
still going to be
no one reads the disclaimer that is so
messed up well i have a question what
would you would you rather be
dead and forgotten
or would you rather something like
that people liked about you but you
didn't like about yourself be brought up
after you were dead i have no opinion i
don't care dead and forgotten there's
something so poetic about just going
back into the soil and being nothing and
everything yeah like that is the
ultimate for me that's good yeah i think
it's beautiful to just
i think my answer is better i have no i
don't care
why are you being competitive when
you're in the ugliest of all of the
swimsuits today really of all the days
to try to compete with her
she looks so much better than that no i
don't mama guys i brought a skims
because i just had a feeling because how
were we going to know if these were
going to fit us right
right and a saggy swimsuit is not okay
you guys we didn't get to choose the
swimsuits um they were given to us by
production and production couldn't know
listen i'll defend production yes for
once and for all
now i was watching your tic-tac because
you're the only one i follow
i'm just getting on tick-tock guys by
the way [ __ ] follow me it's so
embarrassing um
but
you
met tyra banks yes
so i um
i give up i can't be as hot as you guys
forget it it's okay there has to be a
jewish person on and it's just more like
how dirty your hair is like there's so
many other things that are i [ __ ] put
oil in it to look like i was at the
beach it just looks like i didn't shower
okay
we all have different tactics
you're meant to have people to pay
people to take care of you you know that
yeah this really is like another example
of that you should have had hair and
makeup wardrobe for this this was your
idea esther or you could have just
showered and come in with wet hair all
right let me tell you she's never gonna
shower putting oil in her hair is way
more realistic so a couple years ago i
was at an event and tyra banks was there
and i was like
she's just standing right there and she
could potentially be the key to unlock
like me being hotter and i was like i
just have to take the risk of asking
and so i went up to her and i was like
hey
like
how can i be hotter in photos like you
seem like you're the pastor i love
and she's she lit like thinking that she
might just be like weirded out who knows
gotta take the risk she looks at me she
goes let me see your phone
here you go she's like let me see
pictures of you show me pictures of you
she's looking through all them she goes
okay
relax your jaw like what she's like
and then we take a photo and i just go
like this like
and it's the best photo i've ever taken
it's a it looks tongue in the roof of
the mouth
i think i just
my mom's korean you are corpse hot so
anything you can do to look a little
corpsier it's because for me like i i
need to add more jaw because i have like
less draw but do you think she was
saying that specifically to you like you
are a contestant on america's top mom
yes or was she saying it to like that's
what everyone should she was giving me
specific tailored advice but it's for my
face how would you feel if you found out
she had said that to like every other
person would that hurt uh
it worked for me so that's fine okay so
you know what i've deduced from this
situation is that
the role i play in your life when i'm
there is i'm the one you push in to talk
to the person for you i'm like the
buffer in between so if there is a
rejection i take that but if there's a
a go ahead then you can come in yes like
we're we're this way i always say like
we're good wing women for any situation
for each other for you i need i need
that yeah because i'm the quiet mouse
who's going to be like
you know i'm never i would never never
dare out but that makes you look cool
though but that makes you look cool
because you don't read like a mouse in
any way so you're just so hot that
you're in the corner like not saying
something looks like you're like
the best thanks annie i'm really just
like you know no i know but that's even
better but that's even better
so you suffering there's like a pain but
it's kind of making you like like you're
thinking you're like
you're like i was molested boy you're
like my shoulders are big and you kind
of do like the model
a couple of my co-workers at abercrombie
um were on america's next top model and
one of them actually won her name is
felicia
and can you pull her up salisha she's
beautiful
yeah and i had a friend who was i was a
little bit closer to her name was meg
um
but
everyone at abercrombie was either and
as you know this everyone in la
basically but abercrombie especially
they were always in that reality show
next remember that yes
craig conant was on that
someone from my work was always on an
episode of next let's put it that way
that is like when i was a [ __ ] loser
eating cookie dough watching trl after
school i would have dreamed to know
someone on next
that is so cool
yeah so she won that
remember the fifth wheel that was a good
yes that one was that on like
for us it was like channel 13 what was
that fox or something
i think it was five yeah mine was 29.
but i can't remember what the storyline
was they just put five people in and
then two people paired up and then one
person lost yeah i guess yeah but what
did you win in these
nothing you didn't win anything yeah
because i think craig conan said he made
like 15 bucks or something right
yeah that's how we get paid for a set at
the comedy store
it's up to 20 now
she doesn't even pick her checks up
do you ever do that how fun that that
was like a goal in my life was to not
need my comedy store checks because i
remember bobby would come in and they
would hand him like a stack that's
probably like 10 000 worth and he just
didn't give a [ __ ] at all and that's
when he first told me
when i first was in the office with him
and i was like oh my god you have that
many checks he goes yeah he goes you
need your comments or checks i i'm gonna
expose him
he doesn't
he doesn't do that because he simply is
too lazy to mail him mail it to his
accountant so for the past 10 years all
of his checks i put in a big envelope
and i mail it to his accountant because
they're like it needs to be accounted
for yeah
so um you're getting taxed on it you may
as well put it in yeah and so it's like
you know
this boy sometimes like i would
and in the beginning he needed the money
yeah you know what i mean like he'd come
home from like a gig and there'd be like
a twelve thousand dollar check there and
i'd be like hey like you need to give
this to your accountant you know what i
love about that and it'd be like eight
months old and you would lose them all
the time right because yes my my
business manager makes them mail the
check to them because they know that i'm
not gonna
get like and if i do for some reason get
it they will send a messenger to take it
the next day like they know that i will
lose the check and a lot of times the
messenger will get there todd will be
the one there
and he'll call me like what do you what
what are they here for and i'm like oh
the check's actually in my car
and they'll have to send a messenger
again i have the same
right type of yeah relationship my dad
would always say like
you need to keep your money organized
like in my wallet because i never have
had a wallet he'd be like you don't even
know how much money is in your wallet
like that's such a bad sign for like
i think
we got to be more careful does your does
is carlos your wallet now
you just go like put this in your pocket
okay i do have one of your credit cards
yeah that's not untrue
what kind is it
just a chase card oh wait can i just
tell you we were on our we have like a
chat thread with like whitney and like
kesha and amanda's like all these like
powerful women olivia esther
whitney's what did she i don't know how
we saw what kind of credit card she had
no she like flashed her credit card or
something or she said what kind she had
yeah i don't remember and esther was
like we have to get one of those and i
was like esther i've had one of those
for like six months it felt so good
but what does a fancy credit card do
it's a bigger spending limit oh oh
i just have a policy against an annual
fee so i won't pay an annual fee you've
got to grow up yeah but what if the
annual fee is going to stop this month
that's ridiculous how are we going to
get into solo house
cars
membership
that's so funny they're like who are you
he's selling thank you danny downtown
house you do the downtown one yeah
weho's one is just like so i want the
malibu one that's completely separate
oh yeah they have a couple of those i
have a policy against soho houses why
because you can't take pictures no just
because it's like who the [ __ ] cares
right do you want to be
special i'm sorry carlos
you want to be you want to pay to be
viewed as special it's kind of fun yeah
i i guess but i've always had fun going
i've never been a member of it but i've
always had a good time it does feel fun
when like my agent or like aquafina was
in town she had me go like it is fun
like well then here
soho house i'm open to being um to my
mind being changed i want to see what's
so special yeah i just wanted to take
girls there it's like the easiest thing
in the world
every restaurant in west hollywood
hollywood whatever and i was just like
oh this will be a new spot wait are
there good looking people there of
course yeah oh okay that makes sense
that's one thing about my membership
i've been a member for like four months
i've never been
see but that's even cooler right
because i haven't found the right girl
to take
except if it's planet fitness or what
was the thing that robbed you of your
mouth oh by the way they have a
collection agency coming after me for
that
but it's like i don't want to pay them
like it will just [ __ ] my credit ups at
this point i just need to pay but it's
like so annoying i'm like you guys
scammed me i want to sue them i'm going
to tell my business manager to sue their
ass wait so carlos are there tiers to
the membership or it's just one flat out
no there are tiers there's under 27
which is they get a discount yeah it's
just for like hipster wait under 27 age
if you're under 27 years old oh i love
that
i know it's shady out of shape todd
can't get in get that anymore that's
just like how raya does it with like
young hot models
i feel so bad for women who who want to
be on raya i just want to scream to them
like
it's just for guys to [ __ ] 21 year old
models it's not for us it's for ben
affleck it's not even for like
me it's so rude are you on raya i've
been on it like i've been on a bike on
what you've looked at
scroll down i'm a member of riot like i
had the membership and everything but it
sucks ryan's not good well i met girls
on it but like to be honest it's hard to
compete with ben affleck
leonardo dicaprio
it's like matthew perry or something
like how can i compete with matthew
perry
you guys i
love sakara so much i can't believe
they're sponsoring us because i really
truly feel they're the ultimate hot girl
food when i was shooting season two of
alone together and i had like no brain
power energy i just had my sakara my
healthy hot girl breakfast it's all
plant-based did you ever leave it in
your saqara
you have to refrigerate it later
um but i really agree like feeling your
best starts with what you eat and also
what i love about sakara is you can just
order it for five days and have a reset
where you don't have to make decisions
about food you know that you're having
like this it's almost like having a
personal chef for a week that's how i
look at it yeah sometimes i think the
hardest part about food is just planning
it and you're obsessing about it all day
once it's just that's taken care of you
can move on to the next thing you're
obsessing over sakhara's plant rich
ready-to-eat meals and functional
wellness essentials nourish your body
with whole organic ingredients that
retrain your palate and help you break
up with your sweet tooth with your sweet
tooth for good
dave and i had it we did like a three
day i think um together a couple of
weeks ago and
it just was so much fun to do it with
your partner and like it just feels like
a healthy reset the car is nutritionally
designed chef crafted breakfast lunches
and dinners are made with powerful
plant-rich ingredients helping boost
your energy support your digestion
that's a huge thing for me curb your
sugar cravings and get your skin glowing
plus it's all delivered you guys right
to your door skin food delivered to your
right to your door
it is crazy sometimes like after i eat
this people be like what's going on with
your skin and i'm like
i'm doing it from the inside out baby
and right now sakara is offering our
listeners 20 off their first order when
they go to sakara.com
trash tuesday or enter code trash
tuesday at checkout that's sakara s a k
a r a dot com slash trash tuesday to get
20 off your first order sakara.com
trash tuesday what are some things you
discovered on your phone that you didn't
know you were paying for for the past
three years
okay um definitely like fitness apps
that i literally never touched but
somehow was subscribed for years um
embarrassing stuff like like this app i
once subscribed for that like was brain
games like oh i fall for those all the
time yeah and i it wasn't until i
started using true bill that i realized
how many things i was actually paying
for that i never use a lot of times i'll
download i just fall for it when
something's like oh it's only 1.99 but
then if you look at the fine print it's
like it ends up being like 10.99 that
was just the trial
i have apps like editing apps um oh my
gosh i have a lot of those brain games
which is so funny because you're the
dark place you're in when you download
those apps i know we're like i'm dumb
this is going to make me smart and then
five years later you're completely
broken you're like who's the idiot now
no i need to look at my true bill today
you guys on average people save up to
720
a year it's because companies make
subscriptions so hard to cancel but true
bill makes it incredibly simple just
link your accounts with trubil and they
will cancel your unwanted subscriptions
in one tap and your true bell concierge
is there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to you know what it actually helped me
with it reminded me that i had i had
subscribed to spray tans
that's pathetic
is it pale pale one only because i think
you look so beautiful naturally because
i have a spray tan no you look
disgusting
you don't need six different anime
streaming platforms just fyi
one is enough you can just use my
netflix kawhila right and you know i
still have i'm still on your um peloton
you are
i haven't used it but i'm on it no
people say this is the best financial
app they've ever discovered like it's
changing people's lives and you guys we
want to say to you don't fall for
subscription scams start canceling today
at truebill.com trash tuesday do
subscribe to the show though go right
now that's free thank god go right now
truebill.com trash tuesday it could save
you thousands a year
[Music]
you guys the club that i went to this
weekend
didn't have food which means to me oh my
god everyone's gonna be in a blackout
because they're going to be have no food
in their stomachs when they oh when
they're drinking yes and i was correct
so the second night
i had this guy that picked me from the
airport who was so funny this guy run he
brought me
two loaves of bread and butter and i had
it just stashed on the stage and then
when people started hackling
throwing bread at them
and this one girl wouldn't stop talking
she was very sweet she was like a fan
but so i felt bad but she was just so
wasted when she stopped talking so i
went and i just crammed her mouth filled
with bread oh mama bird it was so it was
lit i'm gonna say you assaulted an
audience member well she would have been
kicked out she was very lucky to be
there but um i mean she should have been
gone but then i walked this other guy
wouldn't stop talking so when he like
opened his mouth and i just
balled it up and put it in his mouth
it's so good videos to come
what it was i'm into that mama bird
but i was like throwing like a frisbee
like you've never felt power until
you've shoved someone's mouth filled
with
bread you guys this weekend i went to
like a cool person party
and like i saw vids yeah so i didn't
where were they i on my instagram story
i i got on muter
i
like
it's a different world out there
like
what was it tell me i was at a party and
it was like some like through my like
fashion cool girlfriends but i didn't
know
that hot people
they'll just they keep their pools
really hot and then at like midnight
they all get in the pool and like get
naked and like i'm like this is really
happening were you wearing that swimsuit
i refuse to get in the pool well
obviously your pubes are done
she flashed me in the bathroom and i was
like this is like the least surprising
thing i've ever seen i've never seen you
without a bush to your knees i made the
feminist choice today and i have
a lot of fuzz but you know i saw your um
growth pattern and mine is similar i
just handle it
as a choice look how matching they are
do you really get it though like inches
down the leg i don't believe that i used
to and then i got a couple i i got like
only a few um
what do you call it laser sessions once
and so it's not like fully gone but it's
less
than it used to be i want to get full
laser but i think i figured out what
bush i didn't know what type of bush i
wanted so i didn't want to get laser yet
because it's forever what are you
considering i'm considering like um
because i used to really like a triangle
but
i don't know with the way you are i
don't want you to think i'm like hitting
on you
like i liked a little dorito but i think
i want like a longer like
dorito i like long doritos are good i
like when the pubes come up high on the
um
like here actually
so like i like it oops
like
up to here yes
and not like too skinny but not too
thick like i i actually really like
pubes on women yeah i don't i don't want
to go yeah i don't like nothing
i story okay a little nervous no i'm
like thinking about it
i know that like no pubes was like had
its moment never like but i agree i
think like
tame
it's just so hard for me to ever have
that because for me it's like all or
nothing because there's so much there's
no taming it you never just put a little
product in give it a little
side part a little tease
i'm i'm impressed with how all of us
like
klyla has always been
evolved you and i have been children
yeah evolved what i'm the least evolved
person i just pretend
potentially she is a better no offense
actress yes no offense she's an artist
you are so much more a grown-up than me
and annie no that is untrue we have
projected she's like she gives mommy off
because you give baby off yeah
and you know the dynamic is between us
you know it's not she's better at
homework than us she's asian no offense
you guys are amazing but i am a big time
procrastinator i'm somebody who has like
um that kind of avoidance
where it's like if someone tells me what
to do i will make sure i will never do
it okay so i have been working a lot on
my procrastination and the thing i was
listening to today the
florence scoville shin thing today was
saying um or no wait this was a jim
foreign thing i was listening to it's
jim fortin follows podcast um it was
that procrastination is you're breaking
your word to yourself so that's you
don't have self-integrity which is low
self-esteem
dude yes it's low self-esteem i've i've
been hearing this my sources tick-tock
but like
yeah when you
keep your word to yourself that is the
only way to build self not the only way
but that is a key to building
self-esteem and i've worked on that for
myself a lot like
i used to always
okay i used to be like
i think i'm gonna work out today like i
don't know i think so because i never
believed in myself i was too insecure to
say i'm gonna walk today because i was
like well maybe i won't but also think
about what exercise is right it's giving
to yourself it's being good to your body
so that is true that is how i always
tell people like you don't have to do
this you get to do this right but you're
good at that like there's certain things
but i'm not so i realize now why i
always take like a mental health dip
when i'm not working out and it's not
because i feel bad about my physical
self i feel bad that i said i would and
didn't so you're correct i did break my
promise to you and then that's like
something you kind of want you're
craving that like we're addicted to
feeling that feeling of like letting
ourselves down also i distrust my own
head in that moment where i'm like i set
out to do something that i ended up not
doing then i don't have a full trust in
who i am exactly so your self-esteem
becomes low and what i have to remind
myself is
it's all up to me if i want to go for a
walk
it's up to me no one can stop you know
unless there's work or whatever but like
so i can say you know what today at
three o'clock i am going to walk and i
and like believe it and do it yeah
he he was also saying today on the thing
i was listening to was like
that you um like if you were there's a
study that if you if you have to go into
work every day and people always have
cupcakes there for you
if you make the decision before you're
presented with the
option if you make the decision in the
morning like i'm not going to eat this
or before you go into the office like
i'm not going to have the cupcake or
whatever i don't know why i brought up
cupcakes but um gate was a thing i know
you have to eat a cupcake um
on the show apparently you have to you
have a problem um
maybe you just get heartburn from it you
don't like it um that if you make the
decision before you go in you have like
a 50 higher chance of following through
because if you think about it someone
else had said i don't know where i heard
this it was through one of these
millions of things i listened to but
it's like if you
committing 100 is actually so easy it's
committing 90 is so hard because you
have that wavering part where you're
like oh should i shouldn't i if you just
make like a this is like definitely
gonna happen that is my problem with
working out as well if i feel like i
cannot give balls to the wall effort
then i feel like i shouldn't do it at
all and in regards to procrastination
it's an all or nothing in regards to
procrastination the other layer for me
is the perfectionism yes i have that too
well i will not start something that i
know
i
might not execute you know with
excellence and then i keep saying today
is not the day i don't feel like i can
really you know even though 90 80 75 20
10 is fine that day a little bit is fine
anything is fine that day but in my head
it's like i like the pressure the
pressure then forces me to be like you
have no choice now you have to give a
hundred now now now right and then
you're hard on yourself and yeah and
then it all falls apart so perfectionism
is also a thing i've been like really
trying to focus on and i think because
it does it gives you like that failure
to like even like launch off and like
failure to even you get like paralyzed
sometimes if you're trying to be too
perfect because you're not going to
achieve perfection that's impossible
but perfectionism comes from
um feeling like people won't love you if
you're not perfect and that makes so
much sense if we think about like how
you were treated with the swimming and
stuff yeah so it's like it's all that so
all of those things are love you have to
give yourself so it's like we have to
train ourselves to say to ourselves
things that feel weird you know about
how we love ourselves we believe in
ourselves like i you know like i love
working out working out's great it's
good for my body i feel good like you
just have to keep like talking to
yourself in a way
that um makes you actually do the action
i agree it's it's always shocking to me
that the nicer i am to myself the more i
get done the more i'm productive the
more i'm a better worker
it's when i'm hard on myself like you
didn't do this that's a that's a
disaster yeah i then i'm worse and like
but it's so hard it's i'm always
fighting the instinct to be mean to
myself yeah me too it's hard to be mean
to you
[Laughter]
it's hard to be like today you can just
to be easy but if i
but it's weird then i would actually be
more productive if i said yeah easy
today i don't know i will say that i was
[ __ ] up i thought i i you know i have
these uh food restrictions for my tmj
diet that i'm on and on the road it's a
little bit hard to follow those but i
just haven't been worrying about it i've
just been trying to make good choices
and when i don't i don't like shame
myself or anything and i was like not
gonna weigh myself because i was like oh
what if i like
gained weight or whatever sorry i'm
talking about weight guys i know this is
hard for you but
um i
so then i like weighed myself and it was
crazy i weigh less than i did
since i like gained weight in the
pandemic because i just stopped like
i'm not like
clinging to it it's just like whatever i
have to say like intuitive eating
personally like i obviously eating
disorder past and all that lifelong
binge eater
the scale is not my friend no oh yeah no
i i would i usually like don't own one
also it's not accurate it simply isn't
accurate
there been many times where i felt the
strongest most ripped most lean and have
been way heavier and
it just doesn't match like you should go
by how you feel and um if you know that
you know you're generally doing things
right by your body [ __ ] a scale i don't
own a scale bobby um after he relapsed
and he got sober he bought a scale
because it was one thing that he could
again fixate on it was almost control
control
and i
had to move it downstairs because i'm
like you have two choices i move it
downstairs i'm going to throw this thing
away i know it's brand new from bed bath
and beyond but i cannot have it because
it can start being fun like where you're
like how much does my [ __ ] weigh and you
like wear yourself before the show
here's the thing so when that weight
that weighing scale was there for a
couple weeks that's exactly what i did i
would only weigh myself after a massive
yeah no other time and really early in
the morning yeah and making sure that i
hadn't even had water or banana i'm like
i'm back to my [ __ ] how quick was it
for me to be back to my [ __ ] i will
say that it did help me on this in this
circumstance just because i went into
just the emotion around it not the
actual act like the feeling of going
into something going oh i have dread
around this experience like oh i'm gonna
look at this and i'm gonna have gained
so much weight or whatever and it's like
i you know then i did it and i was like
oh this is fine and it's nothing and but
it really doesn't it's never indicative
to like your health really unless it's
like it means nothing because everybody
has different body composition yeah oh
yeah yeah different
it literally means
nothing and you just get older and you
just change too it's like if i look back
on if i were to weigh the weight that i
weighed back in the day when i thought i
was like
needed to lose five pounds or whatever
when i was young i would look like [ __ ]
it would just not look good on me like i
just don't
i just really i liked how i gained
weight in the pandemic like it seemed
like the right
thing i don't know oh yeah i felt like
good you know what is also so
heartbreaking which i hope this like i
wish there was a way to put an end to
this but like when i look back at my
journals
from elementary school from middle
school from high school i'm literally
writing down weights and goal weights
there are numbers in there and that is
so
sad was it was it something you saw in
school was your mom really into losing
weight i think it's i think it was yeah
it's i think it's family-oriented i i
think it's family we forgive them we
love them no but i think it's also like
culture yeah tv movies actually bad
boyfriends like people you date friends
and literally like the worst of it was
and i love i'm still fans of these
people but like the nicole richie
lindsay lohan when they would like go
out and be stick thin and like again
that's that's i don't i don't judge them
but that was a part of the culture was
like that was the ideal beauty standard
also when nicole virtue was big was she
not the funniest she was so funny and so
beautiful i remember when they were
doing she was doing something she was
like meeting with a trainer on something
and the trainer was mad at her because
she um taco bell on the way in
i was like i love this special so funny
well that's what i used to always like
when i had gained weight in the pandemic
i was like this is i'm actually like i
feel like i'm getting a little funnier
throw it i mean this is all made up in
my head but i was like i didn't have
that much of an initiative because i
didn't feel like unhealthy so i didn't
have like an initiative i wasn't like
trying to lose weight or anything and i
was like this is funny and obviously my
abs drawn on is funnier the bigger i am
i just the biggest lesson to me is like
or my biggest takeaway on this subject
is like
and it sounds so cheesy and basic and
easy to figure out but like
it's just how you feel how do i feel in
my body how do i feel
like in i don't know in my clothes
whatever
it
yeah it just feels so good to like
remember i talked about a little while
ago when i was like in yoga and i was
looking at my i like decided to like
be in front of the mirror and just
accept myself like not even like judging
whether i'm skinny fat or anything like
just
like that i'm me and it just felt so
good and just the idea of just eating a
thing that you want to eat like it sucks
if you said i don't want to do something
and then you do it and then you have
that sort of guilt around it just not
having guilt and not shaming yourself
and just like
living in the moment of your life feels
so good and i've really i get like help
for that like
even last night carl says i'm sorry i
didn't tell you this no i'm just kidding
i had a small bowl of ice cream and
popcorn after what together and one
yum after a big dinner i went to the
movies mitch i had i had nachos i had
popcorn i had all of it i really respect
that combo because it's savory and sweet
you have to alternate the best of the
best yeah it's like french fries with um
milkshakes oh god they're good my
brother's wedding had that ah so good
really
but like i ate that and i was feeling
really guilty and i noticed that when i
was feeling guilty about it it was
making me want to eat more and so i
really had to be like esther what you
did was okay it was normal and then i
like just had to tell myself to feel
okay but the more you feel the shame and
the guilt the worse you're gonna do it's
and you'll probably even give yourself
like physical
pain too you know you're gonna give
yourself like heartburn and stuff just
thinking like
it's just
love yourself love yourself you just
gotta be like i love myself i love
myself it's so
simple and it's almost embarrassing how
simple it is speaking of um
binging i binged this weekend and i
loved what i binged on because i
discovered something new that i was
probably very late on which is the the
ritz um
cream cheese and onion little oh yeah um
i dusted a whole bag and then went out
and got another bag and i'm telling you
this morning before this swimsuit
episode dusted another half a bag and it
was delicious guys if we're doing
swimsuits on the movies beforehand look
at this you guys i apparently yeah i've
had those those are good todd likes
those my everyone calls them demon
crisps because
they
those those aren't
toasted chips or maybe they are yes they
are that's i just had a bigger bag
um really the best thing i've ever eaten
um and i'm really proud of myself for
discovering a new snack that i can
really really dig into that's so much
fun
i am so proud to say this podcast is
sponsored by nutrafull because all three
of us use it religiously and it makes
our hair fluffy and beautiful i was so
upset when i went on family vacation and
i left my vitamin bag at home because
there are other vitamins you can just
get at the store nutriful is
it though that is my favorite that's
premium it's my favorite i went to my
i've been like dying to do this ad
because i went to my um hairstylist and
she was like in shock she's like it's so
much thicker i thought i had all these
flyaways she's like this is new growth
this is all my hair's coming in
yeah
i got the sealer for my girl and she's
been begging me to take it you know what
i you know what i love about neutral i
love a product that doesn't promise an
overnight fix i love a product that's
like hey these are just good vitamins
that support this type of growth hair
growth this i wish more companies would
follow suit of how neutrophil has like
tackled hair loss because you're right
it's not an overnight fix it's not a
fake marketing thing like it's actual
scientifically backed ingredients that
are good for you regardless
you guys 30 million women are impacted
by weakened or thinning hair for me at
least that happened when i turned 30 and
i stopped birth control and my my entire
head
of hair just came off and i'm just
crying like thinking like
this is just how it's going to be
until neutral neutral offers two
targeted formulas for women that are
clinically shown to improve hair growth
and thickness with less shedding through
all stages of life
and like klyla said healthier hair
growth takes time like you will notice
results in three to six months no it's
awesome honestly like i'm just getting
to that like six month mark now so it's
like i'm starting to see the results and
i'm really excited about it
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafull.com trash and save 15 off your
first month subscription this is their
best offer anywhere and it is only
available to us customers for a limited
time plus free shipping on every order
get 15 off at nutriform.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a
trash can i just tell you some of the
ways my life has changed since i got my
mental health in order i walk every day
i was able to start my own clothing line
i i respect myself i have self-esteem
and these are all things that would not
be possible at all if i didn't
seek help from my mental health issues
i have boundaries with my family like i
have all these wonder friends
co-workers
like that is why today we're talking
about better help which is online
therapy it just makes it all of the
reasons you wouldn't go to therapy you
don't want to have to like struggle to
make the appointment i know i'm one of
those people that i struggle with like
if i if anything's i can finally get the
courage to make that first step and then
if someone doesn't call me back or
anything like that
it's a wrap i'll try again next year so
with better help
it's just easy it's easy and you can get
matched with a licensed therapist in
under 48 hours on top of that they have
this really cool journal feature um
which i personally love to fill out
all the way
because you know in the interim between
my sessions i you know i have a lot of
thoughts and feelings and then that way
i can we can refer to those notes
you don't have to try to memorize your
problems
and it's hard you know they're human
beings too you know it's
we're burned out and when you talk with
someone about your problems that's how
you can figure out what is the source
and the cause and help you address these
issues like at the root and you don't so
many of the doctors appointments i've
had to go to since the pandemic ended
you know what i realized is the most
annoying finding parking oh you have to
get there early you have to find parking
oh it's cash only oh great don't have
any freaking cash oh wait i forgot my d
my debit card oh cool so now you 40 and
i have to come back and pay you you have
my license great this is fun and now i'm
in prison thank you and now i'm in
prison because i got in a fight with a
guy but it's like you can just
do it online you don't have to even show
your face to them if you don't want
better help is customized online therapy
that offers a video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to and that's me a lot of
the time it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours this
podcast is sponsored by better help and
trash tuesday listeners get ten percent
off their first month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday that's b-e-t-t-e-r-a-g-l-p
dot com slash trash tuesday
my friend who my friend works with uh a
lot of girls with eating disorders she's
a therapist and she would always say to
me like especially with things like
popcorn something like that it's like
your body probably really needed fiber
or something like if that's something
you're craving there's something like in
your body telling you to eat that i mean
maybe not always but no yeah it could be
yeah and in the peak of my eating
disorder i had people pry food from my
hand i would like double fist this one
filipino treat called hopia
it's like this round little like filled
they're filled in anyways it's a sugary
dense street
and i would just be
like you know
you know as a binger you're not thinking
you're in this like buzz in your head
and you're just putting everything yeah
like my mouth feels good more and more
and they come in these like rolls and i
would just like you could see like the
my you know no one was home like yeah
the lights are on no one's home and
you're just shoving food in your you
know there's no stopping there's no
stopping
yeah it's from one thing to the other i
mean in my bad days like i would go from
drive through to drive through like it
was dark
um i wanna um
ask you guys something
i feel really really salty about um so
bobby and i you know we we've been
getting pedicures and manicures together
it's our thing how long um what do you
mean how long have you been doing that
just always just the last like two
months okay um
yeah so he's he's very much
a demanding guy and he's like i want
this i want this he wants gel he wants
clear gel because he still wants to look
natural so he knows all the things now
clear gel i've never heard of that oh so
it's very his fingers are very shiny
that's so good his toenails are very
shiny you should get his nails done why
not um he usually does well but he
should get him like oh he doesn't do
what i get
oh i am so the way you like your tic
tocs are really making me want long
nails again but i want to type i never
do but i want to
so we go to the nail salon i
basically just get a basic basic
pedicure basic didn't even get a
manicure it's like just clean out my
cuticles whatever clean out yeah because
i didn't want to [ __ ] you guys
ingrown hair yeah like you know the
cuticles
don't try to shame her like she's the
gross one
we all see you later carlos carlos i
wasn't even giving you like the okay you
looked at everyone like can you present
yourself so basically the cheapest
package right yeah so in your head like
that would cost what like 20 bucks 20
bucks 20 maybe max 40 bucks if it's like
a fancier place bobby gets his gel up
top gel in the bottom and then
his bill was maybe like let's say 70
right
he tips each person the um the person
who did his um feet and the person who
did his hands
50 bucks each
in front of the people who are doing my
hands
and doing my feet
and then he goes and he says beat that
and then now i could hear the ladies
talking to each other like how much did
he tip you how much and we're there
together they know like we're there
together so now these people
are thinking oh we're gonna you know
what you do in that situation you give
them
51
each
just to have the clout over him i i i
was going to tip well anyways like i
think i'm a really good tipper but i
[ __ ] that pressure that he just put on
me i was in a [ __ ] great job but i
had to tip 50 bucks to each person that
did mine on a 40 bill
i had to i had to at that point right
yeah
yeah
there was no choice like it would have
been better honestly it would have been
a better move of his to do it
after you'd already tipped to then shame
your tip on top of it so i should have
been 51 then
i would give like one tiny bit more i'd
be like you can't win this bobby but i
will go right into those power moves
with bobby bobby's power move man but
it's not about i will go right into it
with him i don't have his money i don't
have his money that's a lot of money
yeah well i would when we left i would
go you owe me a hundred dollars [ __ ]
money bobby
yeah that is interesting like do you
need to strategize about with tips
beforehand with people like
because you know when the bill comes and
you split it like i i'm always like what
are what are we doing like let's let's
get a team
you know dependent yeah i just have fat
it doesn't i don't look at other
people's tips because it doesn't matter
like they're not gonna like remember
which person it was or whatever unless
we're like recognized by them i'm also
referring to like
years ago like i don't think i i go out
to dinner with people anymore olivia
took us out to eat did i tell this on
here i want to write a do a post about
she took todd and i out to eat when we
were like so broke in the pandemic
olivia munn and she
tipped
like she bought she had already like
paid there was some they wouldn't let
her tip like really fat on the regular
bill so she had to buy like a water
bottle from them too and then she tipped
them like a thousand dollars on the
water but it was so oh wow and then
she's always like i haven't posted about
it huh annie i'm like olivia i'm getting
to the post
yeah it's just so funny she's always
sending me like when other people get
and i feel like that whole story just
made esther like tighten up and clench a
little bit
no i i think i we all have different
financial situations oh listen i'm not
dropping a thousand dollars i'll give
someone 20 bucks on a taco though it
depends on my mood it's like am i
feeling the vibes and stuff it's i don't
always tip people that fat
it's just i always try to tip over
twenty percent though and just from
being a waitress anytime i have family
members come into town from the
philippines like that's the first thing
that's the first talk i have with them
i'm like this is a tipping country yeah
like you have to tip and it's just um
because there's so much like lost in
translation in regards to tipping you
know it's just different rules for
different countries sometimes i feel
like when i'm out to dinner with my
parents like
i have to like hide the bill and what i
tip were you there that time when my mom
was like looking at the receipt and like
pretending
yeah
she had some like weird maneuvers but
yeah like the receipt was in the middle
of the table and she acted like she
wanted like more chips or something and
was like oh this is here i'll take a
look
it was very oh my gosh
i went out to eat with my ex boy my
parents and my ex-boyfriend's parents
okay and he had a step dad and his mom
took out like a second job so she could
send him money poor boy okay
he was had failure to thrive but he
that's the real thing he really did he
really did and i you know he seems to be
happy now he got a motivational thing
with babies failure to throw he had he
just his dad passed away when he was
little and he just was he was a child he
had some challenges in life but he um
his mom was like secretly supporting him
because his stepdad didn't agree with it
because
you know i think it does like enable the
kids if you do it for too long or he was
30. but she was pretty much like paying
his rent sending him money and stuff so
we're at dinner with his family and his
stepdad goes i'll get this thank you so
much for covering
his flight
so his mom had like lied to his dad and
said that my dad had covered his son's
flight oh my god and so my and my dad
just had to like take it my dad's like
oh my it was just so awkward like we're
all just like oh my dad was like
i just had like grab his hand like do
not
whoa
that must be hard like
i don't know yeah also i have a question
at what point do the parents have to
meet each other
in a relationship like your your
boyfriend's parents and your parents met
and had dinner like what are the rules
in regards to
in-laws meeting each other for the first
time like how far in do they meet
only if it's serious
i lived with him so it was like yeah
that's scary also my family i have like
dated so many guys from new jersey for
some reason todd's from new jersey my
family's in philly they're going to move
to new jersey soon so it's like your
family's moving to new jersey well my
parents want to move they want to move
closer to the boys oh yeah yeah when did
your parents meet dave's parents not for
a while because there we live and all
live in different cities
i think it wasn't until
we met
um i brought my parents to cape cod for
a vacation and then dave's parents met
us there
and we had like a night or maybe like an
afternoon together um
you know i'm always very embarrassed of
my parents like being around other
people so it's i'm always very on edge
when i'm around them just because like
they're just a liability
um that's how dave feels about you every
time i've ever seen him correct correct
um
i feel like i was in no rush for that to
happen and i don't think there is any
rush i don't think you need to rush that
i think you need to be
so
secure because i never want to be in a
position where i'm dating someone and
i'm like are my parents going to blow
this for me yeah i need to be so
comfortable and confident that there's a
common feeling because like our parents
are going gonna embarrass us too at some
point like i just know that
thank god for my mom's um language um
barrier right because i can just blame
it on that i'd like well you know there
was if she says something really like
you know off color i'd be like well you
know english is not our first language
but my stepdad roger he's a loose cannon
because he cannot be trusted he's he's
so lovely he doesn't take things
personally ever so he assumes that other
people won't take things personally he
has a memory of a freaking walnut like
it's like seven seconds so he doesn't
remember what he does who's like rough
you know feathers he's ruffled he's just
like what's up sweetie you know like
he's such a happy-go-lucky guy that i'm
just like i can't take this [ __ ]
nowhere see i love crazy parents that's
the thing like
i
i'm just in i have like some sort of an
embarrassment and fear of my own like
but i love being with them when it's
just me and it's like a safe space and
then i love other people's crazy parents
like if your parents aren't crazy like
i'm out yeah like i want chaos like i
want them fighting like i want i want to
laugh at any crazy thing they say to me
that's so entertaining
safe and comfortable my my dad i don't
know how to even explain what my dad
does he does
he holds you captive like he
you tell him information and you're
happy to tell him my dad's so funny i
tell him any funny story that happens
right and then he has this information
and then he'll like he'll dangle it like
he's going to tell the person you told
them like
it's so funny it's such an adrenaline
rush it's so [ __ ] funny it's like
such a prank but it's so [ __ ] deeply
humiliating like okay so i i had a
boyfriend who
his mom came to visit us and we were
living in a studio apartment together
and
uh we were lying on the bed when she
came out of the shower and she was
wearing her robe and she was talking
about one of his cousins and how she had
always been very butch so she got up and
she was she was laying there so she was
like waist level to her face and she
showed how like every time you put on
her dress she would just hike her skirt
up and she pulled her
without realizing she pulled her robe up
and exposed her bare vagina to us okay
who did this my boyfriend's mom my
ex-boyfriend's mom i love her and she
went like this she was like
okay and our faces were right like we're
snatch level and
it was great it was a beautiful vagina
cuter than mine a little annoying
um my favorite
level snatch level baby that's what
you're that's your height
your snatch level you are snatch level
you're my look she's snatched at snatch
level thank you but um
but my boyfriend like when he goes ma
like we're like oh my god like we're
like about to just like explode it's
like the funniest thing that's ever
happened right but she didn't notice she
didn't feel the gust of wind she was
completely oblivious so i had to like
elbow him like do not [ __ ] tell her
like just let it go like she could never
know because there's no jurisdiction on
that humiliation there isn't if she
found out 10 years later right now that
that had happened she would be mortified
yeah so i tell my dad
the story obviously because it's so
funny right i tell my parents my dad
loves it we're at dinner with them and
he keeps being like past the same like
he's just having the most fun yeah can
you pass the pink fish like i mean just
everything he was saying was like i was
like dad i'm gonna kill you but he
didn't he didn't release the info our
dads are so similar i know they should
get together because i feel like they
might fight but they'll eventually get
together they would never fight are you
kidding physically
i think your dad could i don't know my
dad has balance issues my dad is so thin
my dad's dead let's go
let's go
let's exhume him
i'll have his corpse fight your dads my
dad did okay so my downstairs neighbor
stopped me if i've already told this
story was very like
i had had friends that lived in that
apartment before we moved in and they
were like she's really annoying she
can't stand like just walking around she
gets upset about all the sound and stuff
so it was a downstairs neighbor and so
when i moved in knowing that i'm way
louder than the people that were living
there before i gave no access to this
woman like i didn't let her feel
comfortable to come talk to me or
anything i was very cold to her because
i'm like we're not going to make it
through i cannot be less loud than i am
but so
my dad i tell him that and my dad gets
high we like smoked weed and my dad
starts stomping on the floor he goes no
[ __ ] [ __ ] i was like dad
oh my god dad it's not like we've ever
discussed that i'm loud and i'm like dad
oh my god and then when we were leaving
the windows had those like those like
glass slats that they have in like the
old
so it was like jealousy it was open is
that what they're called the windows
they're called jealousy they're called
jealous oh i love that but so we had the
jealousy pains and my dad like pretends
to look and he goes oh she's fingering
herself but it's like fully it's fully
open
so i'm just like oh my god i'm so
embarrassed i'm like dad i actually live
here and he's like laughing he thinks
it's the funniest thing yes the jealousy
yeah and um
and so i just told him i was like well
i'm just gonna tell her your senile like
if it ever comes up i'm gonna say i have
a senile father
and that's on you love that but it was
so that's what i've grown up with my dad
just
my whole life at risk in his hands that
all the only thing that makes me think
of is like the time my mom picked me up
from school from in middle school
and
it was halloween and she was wearing a
witch costume oh it's so embarrassing
i'm like this is too but that i will say
was almost like my vaccine against
embarrassment like once that once my mom
showed up to pick me up in front of all
my middle school friends in a witch's
costume halloween though like it's so
appropriate
but when middle school you're at that
age where everything is embarrassing
queens are hard yeah and i was like what
i just was wondering how you would feel
if your mom went to drop you off at your
swim team and then was also in a
swimsuit and on the team
because my mom did do that yes my mom
joined our swim team no she did not she
joined our swim team
yes she did and she had pubes like yours
it was so [ __ ] embarrassing i was
like mom you're supposed to shave your
hair
and she yeah she swam there was a 15 and
you can pass them out there was a 15. i
thought you were going to be shirtless
for the banana break
put a banana in your pants too
you would shut up
he's always like no and then does it
see
yes
[Music]
have you ever heard of like the two
minute rule oh yeah i like that one i it
helped me for a while and i forgot it
was something i implemented and then i
went back to being just have it but two
minutes if if it only takes under two
minutes do it like if you're like oh i
gotta wash the dishes um but if it's two
dishes and it'll you know it's not gonna
take more than that then you should just
commit to the under two minute rule i
was thinking um
the sorry was the five second rule where
it's like when you you want to do
something like you're like oh i know i
have to like go take a shower i just
think there's something hard for you
um or like i have to go
clean this thing or i have to go work
out i've committed to working out
you just go you just count to five and
you just have to do it and then you get
up and do it i can't remember the name
of the woman
depression doesn't really
um the depression does not allow me on
some days it just really is this is like
a [ __ ] massive boot on my neck
i can have that's the worst part about
depression is that i can still have all
of these ambitions and things that i
know i want to do but i have
no
physical
desire to actually get up off of like
from bed one thing that's helped me is
that i allow those days to happen now i
don't have depression so i know that
that's not doesn't work for everyone but
i will have days where i have all these
ideas in my head of all the things i
want to do but physically i'm just out
for the count and i'm like that's fine
like i'm just gonna let myself have that
um
i don't know what made me think of this
but i have a question for you guys like
let's just say there was a world in a
fantasy world
where you were in a same-sex
relationship committed like that was
going to be your person
would you
ever want to do a thing where like if
you were going to have babies that you
would get your eggs out
essentially like i would carry
your egg baby and you would carry mine
and then we'd like that that feels like
such a wonderful way to like have
two women have the same baby good songs
so you're each other surrogate it sounds
like it sounds like sperm scissoring
honestly what's that like it's a
scissoring of you're like you're like
swapping yeah it's it's a sense that
like i got you pregnant yeah yeah you
know my egg is in your body yeah that's
kind of cool
but you just sit at home and think of
these things
no i just look at your chest and think
of them
this is my two pregnant stomachs i just
wanna uh assure you though esther we
could scissors you and i all we want and
that's nine there's no pregnancy
no you have to do the what you
annie's has him available so i could
carry her baby any time once a quarter
asian boy
you can get up the half wait you want
the half
i wanted to have it such hell what i did
that was so hard
that was a really hard experience people
don't really i mean i guess some people
talk about it are you fully recovered
yes okay that's it unless i have to use
it as an excuse later this week for some
reason
so carlos brought this up tips to look
after your husband
this is from
i didn't bring 1950s you brought
this is from extract 1950s home
economics book
is that what this is from yeah
have dinner ready
okay thank you todd
todd is the best husband um prepare
yourself take 15 minutes to rest so you
will be refreshed when he arrives okay
that's very mrs mabe um that actually is
great
for anyone just take 15 minutes before
you see anyone yeah refresh
bird bath
oh did it say a bath no
oh i hate this this one clear away the
clutter make one last trip through the
house through the main part of the house
just before your husband arrives
gathering up school books toys paper etc
then run a dust cloth over i literally
think my mom read this and like it yeah
this sounds like yours this is my mom
your husband will feel he has reached a
haven of rest and order and it will give
you a lift too i hate this i'm so the
reason i hate this so uncomfortable is
because i want this for myself
the reason i hate this is because i want
this for myself right of course instead
of having to like come over to my house
but this magazine is training women to
be servants okay let me see minimize all
noise
i'm out i'm out um some don'ts don't
greet him with problems or complaints
don't complain if he's late for dinner
okay we'll go up a little bit but it's
funny count this as minor compared with
what he might have gone through that day
i'm so sick prepare the children listen
to him guys listen to him
make the evening his never complain if
he does not take you out to dinner or
other
forms of entertainment instead try to
understand his world of strain and
pressure his need to come home and relax
the goal try to make your home a place
of peace and order where your husband
can renew himself in body and spirit i
just can't imagine being like a like
stay-at-home i'm dealing with the
[ __ ] kids all day and then your
husband comes home and not just being
like you scumbag you weren't here today
you weren't here you weren't here what
makes me sad
is that somewhere somehow i learned this
and this is exactly how
i've been in relationships
what yeah i've always cook i always
freshen up before someone comes near me
i always um i mean i do a baby wipe to
the vagina you know the vagina but the
ass first asked the vagina she wipes
some version of it
in the pee pee hole
i clear away the clutter
i always clear away the clutch ester
puts one in the stink and two in the pan
and no one in the pink and two in the
stink
i'm wait so kalyla
but come on you know never complain it
was put in my head that i was
useless like what a shame you are if
if you don't know how to cook but that
applied to both men and women growing up
it wasn't just a woman thing because i a
lot of my male um cousins and uncles
everyone cooks but it's more like you
have to know how to cook i'll say this
when i do get energized and like make
things tidy and you know make a turkey
wrap and do little things like that i
feel good i like it but for me what's
triggering i think is like that this was
in a magazine and this is like what they
were telling women to do that makes me
so uncomfortable for some reason
yeah it's it's horrible because now i
feel like mostly i do these things for
myself when somehow it was maybe
initially put in my head that it wasn't
for myself so i'm confused about yeah if
this was like how to treat yourself at
home would be like that would be better
yes but also this is why [ __ ] burn
their bras after this like things went
crazy in the 1960s people went nuts they
were like [ __ ] everyone growing their
armpit hair out like yeah they were
about don't worry
we took care of it you don't have to be
triggered by this thank you but i do
want to do this for myself oh my god
carlos is trying to cancel himself
you know what this actually they're not
wrong about this because i have put my
bare [ __ ] on bobby's face while he
plays warzone and he is not
like and he just will not flinch he's
just like
he'll just move his head to the right of
my [ __ ]
have you ever dated the guy the guy that
i like i always felt was gay that i
dated in college who's married to a
woman and has kids but i'm like gay men
would like reach out to touch him and i
was always like not yet
he if that was a mirror that would have
been him he's just wait wait wait a
second annie you guessed another guy was
gay but you were wrong and he it's i'm
not wrong he's definitely gay every gay
man approached him wanted him everything
he made a choice to repress that and
have children and okay
and live a comfortable life but
a choice happy pride
happy pride
pride to you sir pray the gay away
um do you know they still have those
camps the parade at the gateway camps oh
yeah
camps are real but i mean i guess roe
versus wade's getting overturned
what is anything
we're gonna start having to do the 1950s
wife but don't you think that is
something that might come back into
style conversion therapy no no that does
exist yeah i know it still does yeah
why'd you get quiet like i know i mean i
heard about it no
i wasn't trying to like make a joke
about it i thought you were saying it
would come back into style that's all no
but i'm just saying what if like that
1950s like housewife would come back
into style
i feel like there's women out there
betraying all of us who are doing this
yeah but would it be nice to know how to
cook though it would be like like it is
just like a skill set for survival no
you know what the our challenge is we
should all be our own 1950s housewife
let's [ __ ] do that for ourselves well
that's what i've been literally thinking
in my head i want to do that like i want
to become i don't want to
no that's the trash tuesday nineteen
fifteen housewife challenge here's what
i'll say guys like the whole cooking
thing i'm an advocate for people
learning how to cook yeah only because
like i find joy in cooking for myself
and
obviously dark times ahead just in an
apocalyptic world let's just know how to
throw a fish on a girl or something like
that and i wonder if these jokes are
going to help
hey guys don't kill me always there's
always been adjuster throughout history
so you guys are good
um i yeah no but i for me i think one of
the reasons i don't like to cook just
because my mom did cook but she didn't
seem to like enjoy it like it wasn't
something that i looked at but her mom
enjoyed it so i think that's how she
learned but i think like um
because i have 80d i don't even want to
label myself with add anymore because i
do think i can transcend it but um
time management and stuff has always in
the past been like a problem for me and
so i think it's just it's daunting to
have to be timing different things and
stuff it's like a little bit i think
that's the reason why i'm not a good i
don't bake and i don't enjoy baking
because it's very mathematical and very
precise and it involves a type of
specificity that i don't enjoy like when
i cook i like to eyeball things i like
to look at what's in my fridge and throw
it all together and see like what i come
up with and if you have a weird thing
about time do one pot recipes yeah just
throw stuff into a pot and you don't
even have to think about time you just
kind of have to look and be like oh and
then taste is it ready is it not like
trust your instinct like i like that
better because i think another thing is
i'm like anti-authority and so it's like
i don't like the recipe i'm like why you
[ __ ] tell me what to do and then i'm
like i have to go to the store and be
like oh i gotta go down this island i
gotta get like i always five turnips i
think recipes are just for me like loose
suggestions i look at a recipe i look at
the ingredients i always switch things
around and i think that uh the chef roy
choi teaches a master class on how to
like cook from your heart yeah rather
than like from very specific recipes and
i think that that's where the joy of
cooking comes from i do love like i love
watching top chef it's like one of my
favorite shows and i love seeing where
you you can see because i don't think
they're are they allowed to have recipes
on there um i'm not sure i don't watch
top chef
i think like i think they have to just
kind of like know what they're doing but
you're so creative both of you are so
creative i just imagine you guys like
having fun i've had some creative things
they can't have recipes that's the point
of this yeah
yeah
that's cool that's the whole point of
the show i've watched every season of
the whole through line of the show
it's what makes the show different but
you know what i realize that i do
especially with reality tv that i really
like and maybe all shows i have to pay
attention so i can re-watch it and feel
the joy of re-watching it again without
really remembering what happens like
i've watched every season of survivor
three times i have a show pitch for you
i think that it will it changed me and
bobby's life is the the great british
bake off i find it so boring i think
dave watches that it's to me the most
wholesome feel good show that i've ever
i don't know why i couldn't i just was
like and todd will make fun of todd's
funny
you know i really get so bored when i'm
watching something i and dave likes it
quiet in the room
i like it's not gonna happen hold on
let's go back to the 1950s
if you're going to a movie with me
you're getting
you cannot complain
you're getting the [ __ ] mystery
science theater joke track with it okay
see i would see movies with you because
that's what i need a couple forms of
stimulation like i want to chit chat
like i want to comment it's too boring
during a movie i'm either talking and
making jokes or asleep i'm okay with
that by the way in the movie it's just a
little crosstalk it's hilarious my dad
my mom sat between me and my dad during
when we went and saw brokeback mountain
because she knew we were gonna talk but
we just leaned over and made jokes the
whole time i love doing that the one
thing that bothers me in movies though
jenna did this one thing it drove me
[ __ ] crazy carl's already laughing
she wasn't talking but the brights on
her phone she was texting and like every
and it was a movie that i had already
watched and i really wanted her to watch
like this is the good part and i could
see her she cannot watch you can't even
go you can't ever want someone to want i
think that's been a problem i do that
with song they'll be like listen and
people just want nothing to do yeah
that's your problem for thinking jenna
would watch a movie with you but also
the phone light i could see it in like
my periphery and i was just gradually
like i can't [ __ ] watch a [ __ ]
movie you know but also it was
distracting me yeah here's what i don't
i've never understood why
is a date
seeing a movie you're not [ __ ]
talking to each other it's the worst
date ever so you can get fingered
if you wear pants to a date night out at
a movie or a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
exactly right so it's only it's only the
correct date if you're younger and have
no other place to be
it's like it's a good place to like make
your move you know it's like so exciting
you're like watching the movie but
you're like
controversial i do not break bread on a
first date i
eating is such a joy for me i do not
want a new person judging how the [ __ ]
i'm eating and i will never have go to
dinner like dinner and a movie [ __ ]
that's like the worst yeah i me and
dave's first date was
well i don't know if i've told this on
here but he asked to come to one of my
shows right
and when we walked in i saw i was
already so hesitant but then i saw it
was a very light crowd and i was like um
you know what i'm not going to go up
tonight and so so smart i know i really
called an audible and it was the right
call and then we went next door
i think it was coffee bean now to
starbucks but um we went to coffee bean
and we just had like green tea and we
just sat and chatted and that was
perfect sip a tea have a public place to
sit and chat love that yeah and not out
i think i know which one you're talking
about though it's like a nasty
back oh yeah that coffee it's like a
gross coffee but we sat outside yeah
also another thing that people do on
first dates which i don't recommend
because i've it's hiking
because not only are you oh my gosh it
smells like [ __ ] by the end
i get the
what do you try to push you
you get the little crust the white
stickies on the side of your mouth
because you're dehydrated and now you're
talking you never bring enough water now
you're like sharing this one water
bottle like don't drink too much no i've
done the mistake where like i tried to
eat less that day so i would feel skinny
for the date but then you're on a hike
and like you're dizzy i'm basically near
passing out like so i'm not functioning
it was horrible
i'm i've never been more confused
i've never felt more confused
it's a little bit about the things you
like i love chest hairs oh yeah i like
these i have the um did she just post
that yeah oh i got to post mine from
when i was kylie just posted that 35
minutes ago yes i get to repost that
look we why are we psychic people that's
the same brand as this probably
she really just took boardwalk humor and
ran with it yeah right she stole my
boardwalk humor you know that's my yeah
bye guys thank you so much don't be
insecure
don't worry about nothing why'd you
point at me i am insecure don't be
insecure be cool like me
uh this is a great episode i had so much
fun thanks for coming to baywatch with
us see you next week thanks for bay
watching us subscribe subscribe we gotta
get to 200. i've already threatened to
be gone off this earth
bye guys bye guys thank you
you